hallo freude der welt ich habe mir ein
tesla gekauft ich bin damit quasi also
eine mischung aus kann die und robert
habeck also ein heiliger dabei verdammt
gut aussieht
[Musik]
er hat ja mal gesagt sei die veränderung
keine karte
hab ich mal fahren
[Musik]
heute mobilität kapitel 10 diesel gleich
null emissionen elektromobilität dass es
damit kinder das alles im griff
klimawandel die luft in den städten
alles was kosten die müde
ja gut moralische überlegenheit die war
immer schon ein bisschen aber ich sag
mal so null emission was emissionen
angeht sind elektroautos tatsächlich
besser als autos mit verbrennungsmotor
die autos aber als das zu bezeichnen ist
totaler quatsch
denn die akku herstellung ist alles
andere als dem missionshaus und
verbrauchen wahnsinnig viel energie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unter strom fürs laden kommt bei unserem
heutigen strommix um 40 prozent und
frauen und steinkohle
das heißt jedes elektroauto hat bevor es
das erste mal überhaupt losgefahren ist
einen gewaltigen co2 rucksack nicht mehr
das audiobuch klein
ganz weg ist aber auch erst nach 60.000
kilometer also vier bis sechs jahren ja
gut das mag ja sein
danach hat er eine wesentlich bessere
klimabilanz das heißt ich muss einfach
nur möglichst schnell 60.000 kilometer
runter und was für autos baut die
hersteller dann fette fette fette karren
mercedes audi und jaguar bauen
elektrische suv porsche baut 600 ps
rennsemmel und so tester hier der weg
allein 600 kilo akku sind da drin für
den braucht man unmengen lithium und
kugeln rohstoffe für die man die ärmsten
in afrika und südamerika ausbeutet was
wir brauchen sind nicht mehr im auto
sondern einfach nur weniger autos ja da
bin ich ja schon völlig der chor klar
weniger autos aber die kommen dann nach
holland kapitel zwei elektrisch rettet
die welt
und eben schon 2016 waren 15 prozent
aller neu gekauften fahrräder in
elektrisch
deswegen hat auch wieder in arcore
scheiße und der ist nur fünf jahren
kaputt die weltweite recyclingrate von
lithium ionen akkus liegt gerade mal bei
das ist nicht umweltfreundlicher als
normalfahrer zu fahren das ist ein
haufen scheiße so freunde achtung ich
hab im kofferraum eines tesla noch eine
kleine rolle für die extra meile
laut einer umfrage sind die hälfte der
bürger der ansicht escooter würden einen
wichtigen beitrag zum klimaschutz
leisten
wir setzen aber nicht das auto wir
fahren leute die vor zu fuß oder mit der
bahn unterwegs waren
die sorgen für noch mehr verkehr mal
ganz abgesehen davon dass wir darauf
aussieht wie ich hörte mein charakter
es ist total bekloppt beim auto wissen
von benzin auf elektro und beim fahrrad
und beim roller zu küssen wir auf
elektro und herzlich willkommen bei der
dinge die schon ewig mit muskelkraft
laufen jetzt plötzlich willicher müssen
praktische hüner in hannover
richtig drin auch sie zu hause ein
herzliches bekommen ja endlich nicht
mehr vertreten auf dem tretroller der
wird jetzt von alleine
[Applaus]
entschuldigung wir arbeiten aber auch
schon an neuen tollen dinge wie zum
beispiel dem elektrischen rhönrad
und wenn sie jetzt vorbestellen bekommen
sie gratis das neue umweltfreundliche
elektrische klopapier auf die neuen
scheiß zu kaufen
kapitel 3 carsharing reduziert den
verkehr dass da das mit abstand die als
erfindung ja überall in der stadt stehen
so autos rum und wenn ich als brauchen
und nehme ich mir dass mich das nicht
mehr braucht das schlecht das einfach ab
und das beste sprache gar keine eigene
auto mehr
du hast doch noch eine auto er ja klar
den tesla aber das ist so für so kleine
fahrten in der stadt in der großstadt
gibt es alternativen zum auto bus und
bahn fahrrad laufen mit carsharing wird
in der stadt wieder mehr auto gefahren
gerade die free floating anbieter wo die
autos nicht mehr an festen stationen
stehen sondern überall sorgen für mehr
verkehr
hey
das 50 der car sharing nutzer besitzen
selber noch ein auto genau wie bei den
autos wir brauchen davon nicht mehr
sondern insgesamt geht es so dass ich
unterbreche aber der akku ist leer
schiebt mich mal kurz ladesäule
ausnahmsweise genau das ist das nächste
problem
wo sollte die dinger halle laden bei
einer million elektroautos und möchten
wir theoretisch 77.000 klagepunkte
deutschland gibt es gerade mal rettet
sich hier nicht von der leine war nicht
so gemeint ich soll ich verkauft den und
von mir im benzin die wahrheit tut wer
wird ihr euch schlecht gut so wisst ihr
wie ihr euch noch viel schlechter fühlt
indem er die nächste folge verpasst ja
oder abonniert einfach diesen kanal dann
passiert das nicht nein